peut-on concevoir un enfant pour qu'il
sauve sa grande soeur une sorte de bébés
médicaments
c'est en tout cas le choix d'un couple
du colorado qui a sélectionné un bébé
éprouvette au milieu de plusieurs
embryons pour sauver la vie de leur
fille de 6 ans la petite molly est en
effet atteinte d'une maladie génétique
mortelle explications d'olivier sainte
marie adam à deux mois il est né pour
servir de traitement à sa soeur molly
atteinte d'une maladie sanguine mortel à
la naissance de ce petit garçon on a
immédiatement prélever du sang dans son
cordon ombilical
ce sens riche en cellules a été utilisé
pour effectuer une greffe de moelle sur
molly pour créer à dents on a stimulé la
production des ovaires de sa mère 15
embryons ont été recueillis fécondés in
vitro en laboratoire ils ont commencé
leur développement
au troisième jour on a prélevé sur
chacun d'eux une cellule pour faire le
test génétique
c'est ce que l'on appelle le diagnostic
préimplantatoire sur les quinze un seul
embryon s'est avéré st il a alors été
réimplanté dans l'utérus de sa mère la
famille match était non seulement sûrs
d'avoir un petit garçon en bonne santé
mais en plus il s'avérait être un
donneur compatible pour la
transplantation
on saura dans huit jours si la greffe de
la petite molly a réussi dans ce cas les
médecins estiment ses chances de
guérison à 90% en france depuis 1997 le
diagnostic préimplantatoire est
autorisée mais seulement dans le cas de
maladies incurables tels que la
mucoviscidose la myopathie ou l'anémié
de fanconi maladie dont souffrait la
petite molly
cependant il faut se méfier des dérives
le désir d'enfant est celui d'un enfant
remède d'un enfant finalement qui serait
procréer comme réserve de cellules pour
traiter un autre enfant je vois là un
grave problème éthique une atteinte
véritable à la condition humaine
une nouvelle forme d'esclavagé
biologique
pourtant dans certains pays comme la
grande bretagne ou les états unis
on parle déjà d'utiliser le diagnostic
préimplantatoire de manière plus large
notamment pour le dépistage de gênes
favorable au développement du cancer